hey guys just wanted to let you know i
will be in phoenix
the house of comedy september 16th
through the 18th
and this episode of the honeydew is
brought to you by green chef
skillshare and keeps more on that later
let's get into the duke the honeydew
with ryan zickler
[Music]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler
ryan sickler.com ryan sickler on all
your social medias
um look thank you right now thank you
this community continues to grow
thank you for supporting the show the
message is
thank you for just believing in it thank
you for submitting your stories to the
patreon we're we're right around 100 000
subscribers in a year
and like i say i'm just keeping my head
down i don't know i don't know if that's
good progress but i [ __ ] feel like
it's good progress and all that matters
is that it makes
us feel good um subscribe don't just
watch people often ask how they can help
the show subscribe to the show
it means nothing to you to click it
means the whole world to us
right um [ __ ] with the sponsors
that's how you can help the show [ __ ]
with the sponsors support the sponsors
and um throw those reviews out when you
can you know that's it
tell everybody about it um
if you or someone you know has that
story it has to be heard
i'm doing the patreon honeydew with you
all you can submit your story to
honeydewpodcast
gmail.com we'll go through it hopefully
we will do an episode together
it's five bucks a month it's a cup of
coffee at starbucks and if you sign up
for a year you get a month free
and you now get the honeydew video and
audio
on monday ad free at no additional cost
on the patreon all right that's going to
run through 2021 can't promise you what
2022 brings but who could right um
you guys know i record here at the santa
monica music center uh if you need
musical instruments or lessons for your
kids this is the spot they have online
classes go to santa monica music
center dot com use the code honeydew
they'll wave the
registration free and you'll get their
first free lesson when you sign up for a
package
get over to the online merch store the
night pants nation joggers are [ __ ]
fire uh yeah they're tapered at the
bottom yeah they got a back pocket
they're sick
um and actually got some dates finally
guys
coming up going back out phoenix house
of comedy september 16th 17th and 18th
i'll get those dates up on the website
you can start getting tickets now
very excited to get out more dates are
coming um
and that's that all right if you're new
here welcome to the show and if you're
not you know what the [ __ ] we do we
highlight the low lights these are the
stories behind the storytellers we're
shining
light on that darkness all right and
today
i'm very excited to have this guest
first time here this is super exciting
ladies and gentlemen please welcome damn
man cena y'all welcome to the honeydew
dance thanks mike you're gonna buy
daniel or dan
dan all right dave yeah we can jump
right in do you want to know how i
wipe my ass or how what kind of porn i
watch how i watch
porn i want to know porn asswiping
dating all that but before we get into
all of this everything and anything
you'd like to promote please
uh just follow instagram youtube
everything's dan the man cena across the
board
um turn your mic a little more there you
go yep and then uh
incited with dan mancini podcast those
are probably the major ways but
yeah same thing youtube instagram's the
best well instagram's what brought us
together thank you so [ __ ] much for
being here i had no idea some fan out
there
and i don't know who you were but thank
you i'm in mexico
and i see this message like yo this
dude's a professional blind skater
and he's a fan of the honeydew you got
to have them on first of all you know
when people hit you up you're like
this could be just yeah so [ __ ] with
me you know so i look and i'm like it
does say the honey doing his
interview and then i but then also me
like i never think anybody knows
or gives a [ __ ] about anything i do and
i'm like
there's gotta be another honeydew show
out there as long as it's gotta be so i
was like you know what
i get a shitload of instagram messages
[ __ ] it i'm just gonna message this guy
then i'm thinking he's blind what are
you doing messaging the guy
but whatever i wonder how many times
i've missed out
on an opportunity because someone's like
ah i probably can't message you because
we're the idiots
yeah yeah think that i think about that
all the time yeah like damn how much and
i did i thought about that i was like
yeah
maybe he's partially blind i don't know
how well i get a million messages that
are like
yeah are you really blind like what's up
are you really let me know
tell me tell me the truth are you really
blind yeah dude
that's it so you message back
i'm talking to you i talked to you right
when i landed from
mexico at lax yeah i was stoked dude so
thank you for being here
i'm glad the internet brought something
positive our way
yeah and uh i'd love to talk to you
about it because you are
a blind professional skater
and i i watch your [ __ ] videos and
you just make me feel like [ __ ] bro you
make me feel like [ __ ] about myself
but you weren't all you weren't born
blind nope all right so
take us through this because this is
jump into it yeah it's a life story
because it's a progression of losing
your sight yeah uh all right so
originally where are you from
quick caveat though i'm not tell me it's
a very um
like nuance to skateboarding but to be
professional
is uh like i don't technically have my
name on a board yet
right it's like it'd probably be like is
that what really makes you
the comedy store or something like that
that's a pro but i do
yeah exactly but i don't have my name on
that board yet you're not only that's
what i'm working i'm not there yet
listen to me that's the goal
i don't have my name on the comedy store
wall i'm a [ __ ] professional comedian
yeah
that does not define professional i hear
what you're saying
you do what i do there you go do you
make a living doing what you do
are you happy doing what you do you're a
[ __ ] professional
all right no wall no no logo none of
that defines us all right
so um here's one question i do have
does blindness is it hereditary in your
family it is that's the disease i have
is a hereditary disease called
retinitis pigmentosa okay so you're
originally from where
i'm from michigan all right and whose
side of the family does blindness run on
it comes from my mom's side but nobody
on her side
that we know of actually had this
disease
then how the hell's it come from her
side it gets passed down
i have it's linked to gets kind of weird
it's linked to my
x chromosome okay so females
can carry the disease but they cannot be
some of them don't get a fact you have a
sister i don't have three older brothers
do they all blind as well so my mom
passing on one of her x chromosomes
being a boy is a 50 chance that we would
get it
so three out of our four brothers have
it no
yeah is that right yep who's the one
that does it he does it he's got eyes
like an eagle he's got like better than
20 20 vision
he kills it yeah he's just giving the
middle finger to all you got
oh [ __ ] i mean it's he bears the weight
too you gotta do all the [ __ ] for me now
so he's got vision yeah he's got yeah
and the [ __ ]
is that like the other two have vision
too like they don't drive anymore
but they actually have like decent
residual vision they can still read
print and stuff like that okay so this
was a progressive thing obviously you're
saying so
um but your mom no no problems none of
the ladies in her side of the family no
problems because the other kids like of
her her sisters
have one she has one son but he's not
affected and then the other ones are all
girls so
because it's a 50 50. so 50 with the
boys what who's the first
how old are you brothers what's the age
difference oh my god they're all older
i'm the youngest okay
you're the baby i'm the baby so who's
the one with the best vision the first
uh second second got the best vision
second oldest yeah
so then your oldest brother is most
likely the first
person they see to start having vision
problems
all right so what happens when you start
realizing that
shit's changing i just went into like uh
normal
to get my glasses for the year right i
had like basic i like stigmatism and
these basic eye
problems and uh how old
i was 13 13. went to get my glasses for
the year
and then he noticed something was a
little different and sent me to a
specialist and i get passed around
through a couple people
and then eventually diagnose like yeah
you have this thing called rp
and you're going to slowly lose your
vision throughout your life this is what
you're told at 13 years old
and there's no you know there's no cure
for it but he told me
don't worry by the time you get old like
there's going to be a cure for it
so fast forward what's he considered old
well it's i mean i mean you know that's
what every doctor don't worry about
right don't worry
by the time you're 70. like all right
well what about between
20 and what about the 50 years in
between
nope but now there is some stuff that's
like
starting to happen with like all right
hold on okay yeah that can help
13 years old we're just trying to
[ __ ] rock eighth grade here right now
and you're told that
you have this thing now is this when
your mom finds out her family's had it
or
they always know they have yeah so this
is what my mom finds out
that she's a carrier of this uh not yet
she just finds out that i have this
okay and everett's all new like
and she doesn't even know she's the one
who's passed this yeah he has no idea
nothing like that yet and uh
just i i mean i'm 13. i don't
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm just like living
in my own world still i'm doing my own
thing skateboarding is the number one
thing in my life
like i i didn't really think about my
vision loss or anything like that yet um
because it didn't affect me right i
didn't actually have an effect on like
my day-to-day living like maybe i might
like at night time
is kind of your vision that first starts
to go i might like trip over something
um but nothing like that i think is an
actual issue or anything like that
and then what what begins to happen um
so that's
13. that's 13 right so i'm just living
life i'm cruising i'm skating
uh i barely graduate high school and
make my way into high school like
so you can see your vision from 13
through high school maintain
i drove and everything okay now during
that time or
and your other two brothers are they
starting to have problems yet nope
nothing and they're already older they
don't even know they don't know they
have it yet yeah
the ones graduated uh we moved from
east detroit like moved to a whole
different city
um i mean that's a whole story itself
but
yeah nothing like vision wise uh
not affecting anybody in my family i
think i might have stopped
driving at night
because that was probably right around
was that when i lived oh no no oh [ __ ]
man
no not even yet high school i was still
good i could drive any time
at night and all that stuff and i moved
to california
and living in l.a you know i don't i
didn't need a car
yeah so i didn't really drive at all
from like
and you came here to skate i came here
to skate and like chase that dream right
i'm going to be a pro skater so you were
were you good in detroit by then is that
why you made it or is this where you
because for me i moved here and started
comedy which is they say it's not the
right thing to do
you're jumping into the [ __ ] deep end
instead of
smaller market or whatever and then
coming when you're when you're
you're ready but your ego always tells
you you're ready yeah a lot of parallels
i think in comedy and skating yeah for
sure
listen seinfeld said it he talks about
the skaters you would think that jerry
seinfeld would [ __ ] on skaters you know
just the way
but he talks about how you guys he's
like i see those skaters and i see them
[ __ ]
work that same trick over and over and
over until they
get it and then when they get it they do
it more and more and perfect it and
that's a lot of the way
you know we do comedy we we figure out
what works
and then it's working on how to make
that great you know
yeah and he's like but plus that's life
that's what life is like
do it again and again and again yeah
and the whole like
at the time i mean skating wasn't when i
grew up skating as like a little kid
like
people really looked down on it right it
was just like some stupid thing you do
nowadays it's like it's like big like
olympics and all this
oh it's crazy so it's been into the x
games it's insane yeah yeah it's it's
grown and gotten bigger but
it's that same parallel with comedy like
you tell someone like i'm gonna become a
professional skateboarder when you're a
kid they're like yeah right you know
what i mean
i'm gonna become a comedian it's like no
you're not yeah
yeah and it's still not real to them
until they see something that makes it
real yeah
exactly okay so you head out
on your own knowing you've got these
vision problems
you're out here by yourself i moved out
with three other dudes but no family
no family yeah no family 18 19. straight
on my own
all right i got a job like within two
weeks
uh right down by the in santa monica
right here we're gonna have a surf skate
snow shop
and just like having a blast cj's yeah i
know it yeah about taking
derrick there yeah yeah good i mean
super good times right i'd skate to work
bomb a hill to work skate home skate the
beach on my lunch break and
just like live in that cali dream and
not i mean not making it within the
skateboard world
as like in a professional any in any way
like that right
like just working within the smaller
industry
um and i think it like you said like
jumping in like he's into like
like the big market like that kind of
[ __ ] with me for sure and i it turned
me off on skateboarding like saw the
industry for like what it was
i was complete outsider in michigan
right you're just looking in and like
seeing all these pros and like
thinking this is like the most glorious
[ __ ] [ __ ] everyone's super cool
and then you move here and you realize
like oh it's actually a business too
you know it's like it's not all fun and
games and uh
i don't want to talk too much [ __ ]
because i i mean i love
skateboarding in the industry but it
turned me off coming from like that
small
that small town and uh
yeah man i got burnt out and i was
bummed and then i [ __ ]
got my girlfriend pregnant yeah i got a
girl so i found it when i was
20. i had him when i was 21
and uh i mean that [ __ ] shifted my
whole world
okay can i ask you do you fi are you
worried
and do you find out if you're gonna pass
this gene on to your son
at this point no okay
vision loss is still that this point i
did
stop driving at night so you're 21
you're a dad
mm-hmm in l.a what are you how do your
parents feel about that do they come out
and meet your
not stoked yeah i mean my my my mom's
[ __ ] amazing
not stoked the youngest one gets his
girlfriend pregnant
i'm [ __ ] working at a skate shop like
just
living with in a house with five bucks
across the country and got a girlfriend
oh my god i think about that time and i
[ __ ] it stresses me out just thinking
about it
it seems like it seems like a completely
different life
an obviously completely different person
which
i don't ask my mom about that i was like
dude when you when you had me do you see
do you do do you think you were like a
different person at that time she's like
no it all just seems like yesterday but
me it feels like
i was a different person that was a
different time i'm with you do you feel
that
yeah [ __ ] yeah i feel like every five
years i feel like
it's a different i'm a different person
and it's that was a different time you
know my daughter's six now and
i'm not look man i'm i'm gonna i'm
i'm such an emotional guy like i get
i'll get [ __ ] teared up over
a commercial but then also i'll be the
first one to be like who are we fighting
you know what i mean
i'm just that and i'm looking at these
videos the other night and my daughter
when she's one and i'm a single dad at
that time with her and i'm like
man how the [ __ ] i i look how little she
is and i'm like how in the [ __ ] did we
do potty training by ourselves
everything
every day i couldn't imagine by myself
meal everything all me when i had her
you know we have 50 50. but
half the time and her mom was already a
parent so she
wasn't this is kid number two to her but
it's kid number everything to me
and i'm freaking out over you know i
didn't know what the [ __ ] um
croup was i'm laying next to this little
baby girl
i'm like what the [ __ ] is that what am i
supposed to do
you know but thank god for the internet
yeah thank god for the [ __ ] internet
um
and i just got all emotional and i was
crying and i
i say this i was talking to christina
pizzitzki about this like there's times
where i will literally look in the
mirror and like what the [ __ ] are you
doing get your [ __ ] together like i'll
do self checks
but rarely do i ever self-check
positively
it's always a negative it's never like
hey man good job today
good job and i allowed myself to look at
those videos in my phone and i just i
cried and i was like good for you man we
[ __ ] did that
we did that potty trainer on a flight i
never broke
i was like nope i'm not gonna just let
you [ __ ] in this diaper on this flight
we're going back to that bathroom
stinking this [ __ ] plane up we have
to but
we're not starting over so it was good
yeah but it built a different
but now it's like holy [ __ ] yes forever
ago right
mm-hmm man but
we were yeah a different well you and i
were just talking outside and you said
how long you've been doing this show and
i'm like
ah and then i was like oh holy [ __ ]
we're coming up on two and a half years
already like holy [ __ ]
yeah different time ago for sure yep
so you're a single dad oh no you're not
single excuse me you have a girlfriend
but you guys aren't married or anything
like that
and um now you have a baby so what
happens next
baby um i'm scrambling to figure out
life
pretty much at this point skateboarding
takes a [ __ ] back seat like
at burn town on it anyways not stoked on
it i'm pretty much over skating
figuring out all right i got to go back
i'm going to go back to school all right
my mom
she was the first one to go to college
and her family so like education was
everything
and i barely [ __ ] passed high school
like i found out
i think two days before i i was going to
walk that that i graduated
one class you weren't a good student or
you just didn't give up i was
skateboarding dude like
that's all i cared about i didn't care
about anything i was like where are you
skating in michigan are you street
skating or were there
on the street skater yeah there's a
they built one park when i lived there
at that time that was a shitty park
um and they changed they changed all the
rules halfway through and like everyone
complains
and [ __ ] all the neighbors hated it yeah
kind of sucked
so i was straight street skating
um and then yeah where the [ __ ] were we
uh oh yeah i'm [ __ ] i gotta go to
school i gotta get my [ __ ] together
and my mom says come move home to
michigan and at the time
the girl i was with was like all right i
think i'm ready for a change too so we
both move
start going to school and like
vision is still fine right still i don't
drive at night
but like we're chill like i still have
my license i'm driving along
can i ask you you don't drive at night
as a conscious decision or have the
doctor said hey it's not a good idea
it's a conscious decision because what
was happening your peripheral vision
goes first with rp okay and your
peripheral vision is actually your night
vision that you use the most oh is that
right yep
okay um so once that goes now you're
like
just blinders on but that night that's
it's
really bad yeah very limited and very
limited site like low light any i would
go into like a dark restaurant
and then like you can't i can't read the
menu and stuff like that dude listen
i have contacts but i have sight i can't
[ __ ] read the menu in these
restaurants
i'm i'm that dude with my flashlight
yeah [ __ ] it i can't
yeah that's some new [ __ ] i feel
like too by the way that's some new
[ __ ]
everything's darker and let's set
everybody as close as they can so we get
more people in there this this
corona is going to take care of that
[ __ ] yep yeah [ __ ] that picnic vibe in a
restaurant i'm paying 15
for a sandwich i want a table
picnic style with a crab feast man the
first time
uh i almost got into a fight because i
was
with my girl at the bar this is fast
forward like years my my vision was
almost gone
but i wasn't carrying a cane around um
and i i kept my girl was talking and it
was loud as [ __ ] so i'd look
over to the left like every time i would
listen to her
and apparently i was staring right at
this dude and like after the tenth time
i did it
he like starts yelling like at me like
hey what what the [ __ ] you looking at
what do you what are you doing he comes
up to fight me
he's like you want to go outside you
want to go inside i'm like whoa what the
hell
what are you talking about he was like
you're staring at me you're staring at
me
i'm just looking like i'm i'm
like i'm blind dude and then all of his
friends catch on to what's going on
they're like yo yo
chill stop stop stop and
[ __ ] squash the situation but do you
apologize so he didn't he was a dick
really he still was like i don't give a
[ __ ] he's still [ __ ] oh
dude he was still i don't know he had a
chip on his shoulder that night
i embarrassed myself one time with a
blind lady
on stage too man it was bad segora and i
back in the day we used to do these like
uh our friend d burdette was a manager
at the improvs and
she would set up these like sunday
benefit shows and it would be for your
your little league team or you know we
did crohn's colitis
ms whatever the benefit was for it was
like all right
yeah all that [ __ ] you can't you
know here's your range of what you can
talk about whatever
and i'm always used to doing comedy at
night
always and inside when you're in a room
like
you don't know if it's day or night when
you're in you just know
so there's a lady an old lady too and
she's sitting in the audience and she's
just
doing the same thing you know she's not
moving and she's got her sunglasses on
like why are you wearing your
why are you wearing your sunglasses and
i i i go hey you two no i was like you
two hey too cool for school down here
and
and you can see the people around her
sort of like uh oh here we go but i
didn't put it together
and i'm like why are you wearing your
sunglasses and she doesn't say anything
and i'm like oh you don't want to say
anything you just want to sit there and
look cool
also even if it in she could have been
like oh i just forgot to take them off
because i forgot
it's daytime outside yeah i forgot i was
used to doing comedy at night so i'm
like what the [ __ ] would you even have
sunglasses though and then somebody in
the group said
she might not even been sure you're 100
talking to her at the point too
she wasn't because the hurting words
sunglasses yeah she's like
who's got
somebody next to her just goes she has
to wear them that was the way they put
it i was like oh
man i'm the [ __ ] here all right put
your foot in your mouth i still had no
idea until that lady said [ __ ] and i was
like
didn't even consider blind how do you
not that's like the universal symbol for
blind
i feel like so no the cane is but the
glasses
are there and i didn't pick that but
it's so out of our
our consciousness like blindness before
i
[ __ ] got thrown into the world i had
never met a blind person
really i had never engaged with anybody
with vision loss
like i don't know like do you know
anybody now like not anybody right i
told you when we were
kids um our neighbor the guy that lived
in the
yard uh like to the side of us is there
we played with their kids and their dad
had a um
glass eye yeah and um
you know we were always like what's it
like he's like oh i'm not gonna and then
one day he did he popped that [ __ ]
thing out
i'm telling you to this day that image
was burned in my head that soft
pink and it was move oh i was like oh
god you know we ran over [ __ ] i was like
oh he [ __ ] took that eye out my dad
was laughing he's like you asked him
i was like man he's like there you go
right there freaks me out yeah my left
eye is fake and i [ __ ]
it freaks me out still it does yeah you
do have to take it in and out
uh you don't have to clean it or
wouldn't
clean it as much as you can as much as
because it'll help it
prevent from like breaking down do you
oh
okay i begged the doctor when i went in
to get it i was like i want to give me a
blue one i want one blue eye oh you
really did
i said that for sure 30 minutes i tried
to plead my case with this dude he's
like nope it's my integrity i can't do
it and he wouldn't do it
but aren't you supposed to do what the
patient wants if it's not if it's not
against what i thought
wouldn't be detrimental to your health
in any way nope but he's like
he's like i can't do it because he said
it was his like uh you know
who the [ __ ] who's walking around going
oh you know
oh is that dr uh johnson's work right
there who the [ __ ] is doing that
because there's only two dudes it looks
good dude it looks yeah i mean besides i
got my
son
[Laughter]
i'm so self-conscious about it too i'm
always i got my [ __ ] eyes good dude i
got your eyes are good dude
it's [ __ ] you know what i mean
honestly if i guess you don't you can't
tell it's fake
no [ __ ] no but you know if you have a
blue one you can tell it's not working
let's
do you have do you feel the muscle
behind it can you move it
so i had it's called there's a couple of
different ways to do it
it's one way thank you so much for
talking about this and let me ask
because i'm so curious
yeah i really yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
so you can
there's one way you take the whole eye
out and then you have like this actual
globey pop in and out
what's the bigger size like the globe of
your eye the actual eyeball
itself and i had uh
is that is either evisceration or a
nucleation
the other way i had is where they just
scoop out
the inside of the eyeball i don't like
the scoop yeah what do you mean that's
the way the doctor says they [ __ ] cut
it they get open they scoop it out and
they put
they put um a ball in there pretty much
silicone or whatever in there
and then they cover it up so you still
have some movement right that the
muscles are still attached
to the eyeball you have okay and then
this is like a thicker lens that's on
top of it oh so that's a
it's not one unit right there no i i can
pop it on if you want me to
do it bro all right hold on get on get
close get a close-up on this
this is nasty can you really do it yeah
let's do it bro
it's not a big deal it's looking oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
so this is like a lens hold that up to
this
so camera your [ __ ] that's your ball
all right oh my god
see it's like not an actual globe right
okay so it's not a full circle
i see what you're saying so yeah and
then they like take a mole don't drop
them
they take a mold dude
i should go wash my hands you should
definitely we're gonna
definitely wash your hands we're also
gonna talk about that [ __ ]
thumb right there you're trying to put
that
shout out to dr johnson
[Laughter]
all right go you want to go wash your
hands what the [ __ ] i'm fine
mommy too he's like no i don't care it's
just i mean it's your eye
man yeah i hugged you when i met you bro
yeah i can't even
but that's what i
when you told me that they were doing
shots out of his eye i thought you meant
like my lens like they were like
no will anderson on a cla
on a crab feast that was a live episode
from the bridgetown comedy festival
he told a story about drinking with a
guy that had a glass eye at the bar and
he popped the
eye out and then he would lay on the bar
and people would
do like you know like belly button shots
but they would do it out of his eye he'd
tip it over and they'd do shots out of
his eye socket same
god damn that's you just made history on
the honeydew
any doctor that will give dan a blue one
please hit us up
i will pass the information on he did
say
he's definitely going to get stared at a
lot more with the blue one because
people are going to be like yeah what
the [ __ ] we got a blue one
they're going to ask are you blind in
the blue one they're going to ask that's
why that's
why i'm blind in both of them
[Laughter]
that's why you wouldn't do it he's like
my job is to
draw to draw people not to draw
attention right right okay that's
respect
that's his integrity but he's like i
know a guy who does like [ __ ] he does
like the
you see like yeah
he's like the one of the best in
michigan so i went now what um
do you ever [ __ ] with people do you ever
take it out and just like leave no hello
or
no i was i'm gonna do that [ __ ]
next time i had a holiday instead of a
mint okay i left my eye
you all see my eye around it the only
weird time was i was
i was with my son and my girlfriend
we're out to dinner
and i'm rubbing my eye there's like a
certain way you push like down into the
left
and i'm rubbing my eye and the thing
popped now and [ __ ] ting ting ting
now on the floor on the table we're
outside in the restaurant and i'm like
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] and i just [ __ ] grab it and i
kind of just duck down
[ __ ] it up
i don't know i can't remember what my
girl and my son says that your eye
and there i'm like shut up because i
want people looking
you're trying to eat your [ __ ] salad
you look over and there's a dude popping
his eye back and it's like
what are you looking at i'm looking at
this guy look for his eye right here
so i had to just duck down and pop it oh
my god dude
yeah you gotta [ __ ] with people with
that i know you gotta just leave that
[ __ ] on the counter like
it grosses me out i'm still getting used
to it i get gross how long have you had
that [ __ ]
uh yeah uh i think i'm going on
three years it's about the same time i
started the honeydew
look at that new podcast new eye all
right let's go
let's go back to where we were was the
worst surgery what i've ever had when
they
when you were talking about okay when
they took your actual eye out yeah
they scooped no i was out but
and then i was like i didn't my girl i
didn't move for like two days
like the house could have burnt down i
wasn't [ __ ] moving did it
what did it feel what is that it's just
it's like it's nerve pain right you've
had [ __ ] nerve pain before [ __ ]
in my legs i mean i went through all the
vicodin
called the ner i called had to call
again they're like we can't give you any
more we can't give any more sorry to get
[ __ ] from a friend of a friend
just to maintain the [ __ ] things
and i'll have to do it again i'll have
to do it to the right oh
you're going to lose that eye too
because it like it gets pain it got
painful
it gets small and the pressure builds up
and i would just be in pain like my eye
would just [ __ ] throb
and i was like so if this one's hanging
in there
all right i was fat
i was [ __ ] i was like fat real fat
got real fat like 238 pounds
there's so much depression and
everything all right hold on we have to
pause here and go back because
we haven't got to i want to know where
you first
really start losing so you're in
michigan when it when it all really
starts to hit you that holy [ __ ] i'm
going
blind yep i want to talk about like dude
it was a i bet you future trip like a
motherf now they tell you not the future
trip but i would you would have to on
something like this how could you not
it was i didn't worry about it
i didn't i never stressed about it until
it actually started happening because
you're
you're 13 to 20 you're you're invincible
like whatever when i'm older when i'm
40. yeah there would be some times like
i remember a couple memories of like
snowboarding and mammoth and like
looking at the mountains and be like
damn
like thinking about uh there's probably
one day i'm not gonna be able to see
this soak it in
right [ __ ] some actual conscious
ideas of like enjoy this yeah but
few and far between and then fast
forward to
man my life [ __ ] took a [ __ ] at
this point
i started losing my sight uh the girl i
was with
and their son split up she took him left
back to california went through [ __ ]
a year of custody battles
didn't see my son for like a year oh
when he was
the most important [ __ ] age like two
to three
[ __ ] just got fat was going to the
bar
drinking pretty much like what i did was
i [ __ ] went back to what i lost when
i had my son right like oh damn i can't
go out anymore like
i was 100 for my son at that point and
then she left i'm going through all this
[ __ ] and i just [ __ ] raged out and
did [ __ ]
back to dumb [ __ ] right but still going
to school
uh i was going to school for aviation
aviation management
which is it is
[Laughter]
on the legion airlines right now yeah
but [ __ ]
my goal was i'm like i got these crazy
[ __ ] travel bills my son lives in
california i'm gonna work in the airport
i'm gonna get a deal work for an airline
or something right so all this really is
to get to be
with your son without having to pay out
the ass pound the ass
have a decent [ __ ] job where i can
live you're looking to hop on any flight
for that [ __ ]
um employee fair yeah exactly that was
kind of my
mind my little plan right
so i [ __ ] uh
right i think i had like a semester left
for school and that's when
my the most of my vision my left eye
like
pretty much overnight went away really
you woke up and that [ __ ] was pretty
much there was a big like pat it was
like
noticeable like what the [ __ ]
something's different you know
and uh i was working [ __ ] washing
dishes at a fleming steakhouse back home
and i was like i was like can't even
dude so oh man
such good [ __ ] meals and [ __ ] so good
but uh [ __ ] where was i
you're you woke up pretty much in lost
oh yeah woke up right
big chunk of vision gone working what
did you say that what is that
so what are you not seeing or is it like
something's covering your eyes yeah
this is hard to explain because okay you
don't
see the vision that you've lost right
your field of vision
it looks whole to me or it would look
whole to you right because that's just
what you see so that's your whole world
you don't actually see like black out
spot or anything okay like that
so it's just limited right uh so you'll
be walking and you'll just like bump
something out of nowhere
but it's not like
ah [ __ ] man it's really hard to explain
of
what it's like to have that field loss
like i said the best way to say it is
like you don't see the vision that you
can't see
right you don't notice a black spot what
you see is just what you see
so but this one was it i guess
at first it kind of felt like almost
like i was dizzy
like my vision was just off
um like almost like my eyes were crossed
and i was like what something's
different i can't tell
and went to the doctor and they're like
yeah like you've got this other thing
called coats disorder on top of the rp
oh [ __ ] where like they're immature
blood vessels that leak in your eye
and then the blood covers the retina and
you can't see
and there's there's no reversing that
either um
so i then i went through these [ __ ]
injections
right in your eye in your eye god damn
you had needles in your eyes stick a
needle in your eye
[ __ ] wait do they numb you in any way
is there a spray or
here's what you do you [ __ ] first
time i'm terrified i'm like [ __ ] this is
going to be intense
lay down uh first they give you like a
bunch of numbing drops here
hold on here's your little kleenex dab
that and then i we're gonna do four
rounds i take a q-tip with this other
numbing [ __ ]
and they tell me to look down and left
or down and right and they put that
q-tip on the spot where they're gonna do
the injection
and they numb it and it burns for a
second and you're just [ __ ] staring
off
uncomfortable hit four rounds of that
and the doctor comes in and he puts that
like that [ __ ] uh
what's that movie dude would they keep
keep your eyeball open like this little
plastic
yeah yeah orange uh the [ __ ]
is it clockwork orange yeah
it's like that she puts this little
plastic thing in my eye look up look
down plops it in there and look down and
right
dumps a bunch of iodine in your eye does
that burn
or at this a little bit because you're
so numb it doesn't burn yet you don't
feel any of that yet
but you taste it in the back you know
you oh [ __ ] in the back of your throat
and then he [ __ ] goes and he dabs it
once with a little dot of iodine
another dot and then he takes the needle
and you feel like a little poke
and then [ __ ] injects it and like
your whole like your whole eye just kind
of goes
like washes over of like darkness and
it's like oh [ __ ] pops it out real
quick
what are they taking that are they are
they injecting something are they
sampling yeah they're injecting it's
called a vast and it's actually a cancer
drug but
it's supposed to suppress those blood
vessels
so that that pressure buildup isn't so
so so they're not leaking as much
to prevent that leaking from going on
because they tried a surgery before that
where they [ __ ] peeled my eye and
they tried to go in there and freeze the
blood vessels
[ __ ] up i mean try and i don't like
that tree and either like experimenting
at this point and all the injections i'm
over cause you said this was the most
painful surgery you've ever had so how
many surgeries have you had
um a bunch of procedures on your face
yeah a bunch of
you know technically the injections are
considered a certain sure
i had one one other like major surgery
where they tried to freeze the blood
vessels
[ __ ] and that [ __ ] that sucked you
know what
the injections were the worst because
getting the shot wasn't bad
but once i left there and the [ __ ]
started wearing off
i would have to like keep my eye closed
for like a full day um
just because it was like irritated right
and like that was the [ __ ]
decent vision in that eye so i'm like
i'm feeling like a baby
we were in mexico i went jet skiing and
i got
like like a [ __ ] kept my contacts in
well that's salt water got my eyes i was
blind i could not see
driving back to the [ __ ] thing they
were just pouring water and i was like
here and i'm over here
like what a [ __ ] i laid in bed the rest
of the night just so i could get my
and i was like oh my god i'm ever going
to [ __ ] see again and then you hit me
up
and you hit me up sorry to god
i couldn't see [ __ ] jeez dude man
all right so you've you're losing your
vision
you've lost your son you've lost your
girlfriend
i have no you're you've gained 200
pounds or not gained
100 pounds the only thing i'm gaining is
my weight
i'm having a good time though with my
friends you know that's the one i'm
and i'm still all right you know i'm
still
i'm still at least going to school and
moving forward like that was my main
like
always keep moving forward like my mom
won't let me [ __ ]
slack right i'm not gonna be a complete
piece of [ __ ]
so and what's your relationship like
with your dad during all this
uh my real dad my mom
is [ __ ] amazing she raised four kids
like they split up
my real dad's a cop uh retired cop in
[ __ ] east detroit
kind of a dick but good [ __ ]
i mean he's just good he did [ __ ] as
good as he could do
he has his regrets and stuff that's a
whole other
[ __ ] story like we're we're still
good though like we still [ __ ]
like i still bring my son and we i make
a point to go see him and stuff when
he's in michigan but
step dad though i have a stepdad who's
[ __ ]
super good dude uh my mom met him when
we were really young
too like still technically like they
were splitting up with my dad's when
they first kind of met
but like complete opposite of my dad
like my
my real dad is [ __ ] full-blown
italian hot-blooded
[ __ ] drop of a hat he's gonna be
pissed yell at you
step dad is like never smoke never hit a
cigarette
in his life never did a drug or anything
um
like electrical engineer [ __ ] doesn't
get angry his whole family they don't
get like
that that weird it blows my mind
i think that's weird yeah but the nicest
sweetest people in the world what are
you doing like everything's that
everything's aggressive like wow i'm
just doing this
my neighbors think i'm [ __ ] i'll be
on science skating just throwing my
board and yelling and
you're right over there yeah i'm fine
[ __ ] don't talk to me i'm just
skating but it's just me
you know that's [ __ ] what that's what
i'm used to i like to think passion is
what is love and love and funk and anger
combined right
i have a little more anger mixed in with
you man i love that
that is great i agree i definitely have
anger in my opinion
yeah i mean i get people like why are
you yelling i'm like i'm not i'm just
passionate about this i'm not yelling
i believe in this it's bizarre though
those two different worlds of like the
mancina side you go to like
it's full italian you know christmas you
walk downstairs and it you can't even
hear what the hell is going on because
people are just yelling and screaming
i miss that so good the smells and
the stories yep everything's an insult
like i love my
i will never forget one i hadn't seen my
one cousin jennifer in like a few years
i went back to baltimore she comes
running up just gives me the biggest hug
steps back and goes
this shirt like i mean i had seen her in
three years you know i
hugged her again i was like goddamn i
love you i went to christmas once my
brother was grabbing my face and
twisting
and like leaving all these red marks on
my face so i had these [ __ ]
like picky on my chin i show up to
christmas it's christmas eve
uncle louie looks at me what'd you do
sliding the first base
you're like i was just getting loved on
like no and then i thought i could never
live that down for the rest of my life
yeah we're [ __ ] we're uh stepdad
though so i was raised
by my mother as a kid single mom
and then my stepdad going later into
life all right so let's
talk about your mom quickly now you're
going through what you're going through
what point does she start to find out
she is the carrier yeah so this i had to
think a bit
um this is uh
this is definitely when i moved back
home and i think we separated this is
when i kind of got
actually some like blood work done to
figure out what's going on
um and they found out that it's this
x-linked chromosome it came from my
mother
um she just and then you know she's yeah
she's [ __ ] feels that guilt right
how could you not i gave this to you
yeah exactly and she's like
i gave you life and took your sight
she's at the same time
though she's [ __ ] i remember calling
her complaining one time and she she
just tells me quit being a little [ __ ]
you know
really like good yeah she's the best
dude she
i mean she raised four kids she [ __ ]
like survived [ __ ] cancer once
she [ __ ] has done so much for all of
us like still
[ __ ] helped support me right
throughout this whole time of
losing my son um like flew with me
all the time back and forth between
california and here
like the strongest person i know right
she's the reason why i [ __ ] keep
pushing
like she's the reason why um
but [ __ ] she got stranded on a desert
deserted island one time
how how does anyone do that i wish she
could [ __ ] tell the story she tells
it's so good
they went on a [ __ ] cruise in the
galapagos islands so these small ships
and then you hop on a little skip or
whatever
and you pop over to these little islands
so they're at this little island
and the system they use is you leave
your sandals on the dock
and that means somebody's still here
right so she's there with
my stepdad he's like i'm over i'm going
to go back i'm going to take more photos
of this [ __ ] turtle or some [ __ ]
my mom's like off taking photos like
just on the reach of the boat
and then some [ __ ] girl
uh gets on the something happened where
she grabbed my mom's sandals and brought
him on a little boat
and she she hears the [ __ ] little
boat take off
when your stepdad's not like hey my
wife's not oh she
this is a separate ride oh okay so
myself that was already back on the main
ship and he's like i'm gonna go lay down
and my mom tells this to her she's like
all right she
pops over the hill sees the boat go away
like watching it go away she's like
maybe they'll come back no waiting
waiting in her head she's like all right
brian my stepdad he's gonna take a nap
he's gonna wake up shower
he's gonna then he's gonna go downstairs
and then he's gonna realize that
nobody's here
that my wife isn't on the boat still and
that's exactly what happened
he realized eventually and my mom was
like pacing and it was getting dark
and she could watch the main ship like
go further and further away
and like getting smaller and right
before like she couldn't see it you
don't even know what's on this island
she said she was pacing left and right
on the beach because she was getting
eaten by [ __ ] bugs
oh and eventually she sees the boat turn
around and they [ __ ]
came back and they got her and they're
riding
they're writing back and they're like
asking the dude
there's this guy in the girl like does
this happen all the time
and you look at the girl she's like no
and they're like what and then you look
at the dude he's kind of just
using the motor he's like sometimes
but made it back but [ __ ] that's my
mom
like strongest [ __ ] woman i know but
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor green chef
green chef is the first usda certified
organic meal kit company you can enjoy
clean ingredients that you can trust
they're seasonally sourced
for peak freshness ingredients come
pre-measured perfectly portioned and
mostly prepped so you can spend less
time stressing
and more time enjoying delicious
home-cooked meals
all right i got a package sent to me by
green chef
i love it i i don't have time to sit
there and measure it all out and do all
that i'm a single parent
i'm running around the kitchen i'm
making lunch for tomorrow i'm making
dinner for tonight
and green chef save me so much time it's
all right there
boom boom boom trying to get my daughter
to eat more uh
different things and this has really
been helpful so
green chef is now just so you know is
owned by hellofresh and with a wider
array of meal plans to choose from
there's something for everyone i love
switching between the brands and now
you guys can enjoy both brands at a
discount with me so here's what you got
to do
go to greenchef.com 90 honeydew
and use code 90 that's nine zero
honeydew
to get ninety dollars off including free
shipping all right
again go to green chef dot com slash 90
honeydew
and use the code 90 honeydew to get 90
off including free shipping green chef
the number one meal kit for eating well
our next sponsor is skillshare
witness your own transformation as you
turn small steps into giant leaps
skillshare
makes it possible i took a workshop this
time with my daughter right i want to
keep her active and now that
homeschooling's been a thing it's not
foreign to do this at all so we took a
workshop on beginning
i'll tell you exactly what it's called
beginning watercolor easy painting
basics it's hosted by allison from
skillshare
and if you go on you can find these
workshops that range anywhere from may
to june like a month long and they'll
tell you when they are you can go on
sign in and then join in the class and
take it and it's been
a lot of fun and really educational for
me
and my daughter uh so do something today
you couldn't do yesterday with classes
designed
for real life explore your creativity at
skillshare.com
honeydew and get a free trial of premium
membership that's skillshare.com
honeydew our next sponsor is keeps as
guys so much of our identity is wrapped
up in our hair from how it feels after
getting a fresh cut to the way it's
perfectly styled before going out
all right i i had never known i always
went to barbers i never went to salons i
had no idea my girl tara's cutting my
hair i had no idea the stuff they do at
salons i'm never going back to a barber
they're giving scalp massages hot what
are you talking about i'm going to
salons all day for this salad
uh that's why when we get into our 20s
and 30s okay and we start noticing
the first signs of hair loss it
definitely feels like panic time
because let's face it no guy is ever
ready to go bald
and thankfully now there's keeps the
simple easy way to
keep your hair did you know that two out
of three guys will experience some form
of male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35
the best way to prevent hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have hair
left get treated from home you used to
have to go to the doctor's office for
your hair loss prescription now
thanks to keeps you can visit a doctor
online and get hair loss medication
delivered
right to your home they make it easy and
deliver
your medication every three months so
you can say
goodbye to pharmacy checkout lines and
awkward doctor visits
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out there
and you may have tried them before but
probably never for this price prevention
is key
keeps treatments typically take between
four to six months to see results
so it's important to act fast the sooner
you start using keeps
the more hair you'll save find out why
keeps has more five star reviews than
any of its competitors and more than a
hundred thousand men
trust keeps for their hair loss
prevention medication
keeps his treatment start at just ten
dollars a month plus for a limited time
you can get your first month free
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
honeydew to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash honeydew now let's get
back to the duke
god where were we i don't even know your
mom's finding out about this she's
carrying the guilt
yeah she has that guilt um
but at the same time i said she's really
strong she's pushing me
to like fighting for me to get all these
services that are like
there's any blind person or somebody
going through vision loss there's all
these services that are free to you
in the united states um that can help
you go to school they can help you get
uh training as far as using the cane all
these things so she's helping me push
and like
fight for these because some of these
things you gotta like it's all this red
tape and bureaucracy you gotta deal with
but uh getting me kind of guiding me
right back on this right
this right path right um i mean it's the
least she could do
took your sight she could at least get
you on
she gave me this deck of cards i got
dealt all right wait you've mentioned
training with the cane so that was the
big change in my life all right so i
want to get to that so your mom now
realizes oh my god i'm the carrier and
then
your brothers have to get tested as well
to see if yeah they never did
because they're they they're just like
they've never seen those we'll know
yeah they're they they started getting
effect i think the one's been to the
doctor everyone hasn't even been to the
doctor
like they're just gonna they're just
pushing it off you know what i mean
everyone deals with it differently
sure um
but uh so yeah so i switched gears right
i've
i finished my little [ __ ] associate's
degree at this community college
get my grades we got a little better
they started slumping a little bit
yeah that's my son [ __ ] women i can
imagine um
and i'm like what can i do as a blind
person like that's what i started asking
myself like what
can someone do just as a blind person as
a career
and like my sister-in-law was a massage
therapist i'm like i can i mean i can do
massage
so i go and i do massage [ __ ] school
for a year
i complete this other little associate's
degree
and i work as a massage therapist for
like a a little chain
uh massage like massage place or
whatever
and uh and how's that and it was
it was all right like it at least it
gave me more independence
like okay i'm like i can't ever
accidentally hit a titty i can't i can't
see
no i haven't but i would have like i
would have people
like get completely naked in front of me
and like sit down like i had a girl oh
this lady one time
like working on just oh hang on she got
up and i know she's naked like answered
her phone like in the middle of a thing
but like i know her tits are just out
but i just can't [ __ ] see them
but i'm like that was weird but [ __ ]
i just remember working i remember
giving massages
like a few times and just thinking like
this is not me
right this is not where i'm supposed to
be this is not what i'm supposed to be
doing
i gotta [ __ ] make a change but it at
least was like a step
right it was like always moving forward
in some way so [ __ ] still going to
school
same time i went to uh
to get my cane training for leader dogs
for the blind they actually do the it's
called o
m orientation of mobility okay and that
gave me like
this huge boost of confidence and uh
why getting my like i got to a point
i went from uh driving
i ran two red lights the second one i
ran was kind of a main intersection i'm
like i'm done did you get pulled over
nope [ __ ] i like underneath the light
i look up i was like oh yeah that's
[ __ ] red
and i was like i got to stop i'm going
to kill me or somebody else
hanging the keys up that day never drove
again legally
and then sorry where was that
um it was one of the things they say for
older people
yeah that's just another piece of it it
wasn't hard then but nowadays
um i wish i had my i wish i could
[ __ ] drive
like come on elon musk give me a [ __ ]
driving self-driving car like let's go
like if i get a car one day that's my
dream yeah you'll be able to have my own
car
um you mean to drive it actually drive
drive have my own car and because
i right now i'm on everyone else's time
that's the shitty thing
yeah like that [ __ ] wears on you like
number one you're putting some strain on
my relationship like my girlfriend's
[ __ ] sitting outside right now yeah
in the car you know she could come
inside yeah
she's super awkward she won't do it
she'd probably feel weird in here but
uh you're putting that strain right on
people
and then i mean uber's [ __ ] huge
um uber and lyft was a game changer
actually this is what you don't think
about when you
yeah i never even realized how important
uber and lyft and ride shares are
in the blind community never even god
damn yep
embarrassed i have never even thought
like what uh even if
did anything like that exist for the
blind before other than like the
vans we would see and [ __ ] like that
yeah no there's some uh
some public it depends on where you live
um there's some
you know public like transportation the
city i lived in does not have
public transportation okay um
so like la was nice time you know i'm on
everyone else's time right even uber
stopped because i got a [ __ ] order
and i'm waiting and that's
you know i'm paying 30 one way to go to
these places right
nothing wears on you but uh yeah i went
from
where i was i went from driving to
riding my bike everywhere
which was chill where i was at i was
just kind of in my area going to school
i stopped doing that vision kept going
lost the left eye
kept progressing right eye started doing
the same thing
lost the majority of the vision in my
right eye and i got to the point where i
wouldn't
i couldn't leave my house and like even
walk around the block
unless i was with somebody else because
i didn't have that
experience or knowledge of of how to
navigate can i ask you this
if you remember what's do you remember
the last thing you actually
saw um
no no it's just that weird
weird like progression like i had
for many years when i started skating
and i had this little chunk of vision in
my right peripheral
um and the best way to explain it would
be like
looking through like a really hazy
[ __ ] window screen
okay looking through just a nasty screen
right
so like i couldn't see detail like i
couldn't read i couldn't if you showed
me a screen
i could tell if that screen was on or
off if it was bright i could see that
light
but that's it okay um and now you told
me we're outside that
even standing in bright daylight on the
beach or in a dark room you
couldn't tell no difference yeah wow
visually there's no difference
from sight all the way to that all the
way to the end
i'm watching you walk with this cane i'm
marveling at that like i'm trying to
help you not stepping dog [ __ ] out there
and stuff is a dog [ __ ]
you know how many times i step into that
i believe it dude how many times i've i
[ __ ] reached down
on a bench like what's this hey heather
what is this
oh that's pigeon [ __ ] you're picking up
i want to lighten it a little bit here
and talk about some things i want you
mentioned you want to know how white my
ass i do want to know how you wipe her
out
yeah i want to know um you have a
girlfriend who you had obviously when
you had sight but i do want to ask you
some questions about
what if she was gone i want to know if
anybody's ever ripped you off or you've
caught them trying to rip you off and
scam you because you're blind
like any [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] i want
to know these things so
um and then we're going to come back to
some [ __ ] but how do you
so how because i look i might get this
wrong do not quote me on this but i'm
pretty sure it was bert kreischer
uh the segura told me this burke
chrysler joke early on
um and maybe maybe it was someone else
and bert told it but
the way i remember it it was bert i'll
have to ask him but
he was at his show embarrassed himself
with a blind person
and um i guess he was [ __ ] with this
guy and he
said to him he goes oh you're blind he
goes hey how do you wipe your ass he
goes because for me
i i know i'm done when it goes brown to
clear
or white or nothing brown red he said
i know i'm done when it goes brown brown
red
i start to laugh it's so horrible anyway
the way
you know that man has hemorrhoids he got
upset and he left
the guy left and then one of his buddies
came back like hey it's not really you
he j like he just went blind oh
it was like he had sight and all of a
sudden he's now blind and he doesn't
know
how the [ __ ] he's gonna white you know
what i mean like you're asking him [ __ ]
he's over there probably been pondering
the whole time
um so how do you know
uh no i mean you oh it's everything you
do actually
you use this this rule of overdo it
okay when i clean the [ __ ] countertop
after i cook you over
i go an extra 10 extra couple feet to
the left uppercut street to the right to
make sure i get everything
okay you wipe a couple extra time and i
use if i have a bidet now there you go
and i don't know
dude yeah like game changer game changer
yeah i can't
you shooting without it is [ __ ] gross
it is it's like
yeah we need to need to push that more
you got toshi
yeah they're the best yeah [ __ ]
amazing so um all right
what about i know you have a girlfriend
if you were gonna date
like i remember i remember ray he would
grab around the wrist to see the size of
the lady you know
and uh i remember earthquake because
it's in the wrist right
it's in the wrist um
man well you can't you cannot judge off
a voice that's
that's what i'm saying like if you're
blind and you're gonna meet a new person
you really have to love that person yeah
that person
yeah forget about what they look like or
any of that you've got to love that [ __ ]
that person's got to be
great yep it's been a change of like
i mean it's been a few you know years
now of me living as a blind person and
like slowly i lose these
these things that are important to the
sided world like like [ __ ]
oh my shirt has a stain on it like i
don't [ __ ] care like i
can give [ __ ] if my five holes in my
shirt or whatever little stuff like that
and then yeah like people man like a
person's voice is really important to me
now
um it's hard as i'm i am a very visual
learner
um what do you mean by that like like
when i would drive i wouldn't memorize
then the street sign
the names of the streets i would know
like oh everything's right
right that old broke down car yeah very
visual
especially names of people i have to see
their face and now i'm [ __ ] the worst
at names like i'm bad i have to meet you
a million times and most
a lot of people's voices until i really
hang out with you like a good handful of
times i'm not gonna know your voice
um so when people come up to me there's
always like the 30 seconds of who the
[ __ ] is this
i'm doing that with sight like either
it's like yeah it's like does this
person know me from skating and i don't
actually know them
or do or is it like somebody like like
[ __ ] my close
homie sometimes like oh it's eric i'm
like oh it's [ __ ] my close buddy
so that's weird so i like people with
really unique voices
you know like your [ __ ] laugh is
[ __ ] dead giveaway oh that's fine how
did you find the show
um how'd you even find this show i heard
you on
whose podcast was it uh
it might have been wanted this maybe tom
segura i don't know
um yeah i think it was the two bears one
cave one i think i heard you talking all
kinds of crazy stories something like
this dude's [ __ ] asking me about the
hose
oh yeah oh that like yeah the back of
the good old days yeah yeah
i was like this was [ __ ] hilarious
and uh
yeah i think you mentioned your show on
there and then i started looking into
youtube and then i saw the joey coco
diaz chronicles and i was like oh [ __ ]
yeah because i've been listening to him
[ __ ] joe rogan for years every time
there's a coco
diaz episode so can i ask you i have two
questions one
are you how do you use your is it
braille for the apps like what do you
nope it speaks um like
is there a braille keyboard on a phone
uh
there's a braille display where you can
use it kind of like braille
so like anything i touch on the screen
it'll read to me it's like that said
stickler ryan it's on the corner every
time like where the address is
oh okay so when i said we're on the
corner of such and such
and so not just you don't know where to
[ __ ] this place um
but yeah so just anything you touch on
the screen that speaks to you
um and then there are like actual
braille displays where you could hook up
to your phone for like if you're
searching the web
and then it would actually give you like
all of the written information in
braille
that would all pop up okay but they're
like you know five
five grand for like a braille display so
can i ask you a question it might be
sensitive
sure i mean you did pop an eye out on
this [ __ ] show
you don't get to watch what your son
looks like
how he changes and grows into a man does
that [ __ ] with you
no because i thought about this a lot
um and i thought it was a lot when my
doctor when i was going through all
these surgeries and these shots
i'm like i'm over it i'm done like this
is
like we're just i'd rather go blind now
when i'm younger
than me go blind when i'm [ __ ] 50 wow
like that's going to be way harder to
transition
into [ __ ] daily life
uh and he didn't understand he's like
don't you want to see your son
and at this point i still i couldn't
really see his face anyways i'm like
you i don't have to
we have all these senses right i can
still experience
the same emotions that you would get
from seeing my son do something
i can experience the same emotions have
the same feelings
uh through hearing him like laugh or
you know tell tell a joke for the first
time or [ __ ]
accomplish something you know what i
mean like you get the same
feelings and enjoyment out of life it
just comes from from a different sense
whether it be feel touch um
[Music]
it's all it's mainly audio you know
auditory nowadays but
is your hearing killer no it sucks
everything i always thought like if you
lost yourself yeah that's the other guy
you're like i got a better sense of
smell now i like
you use it more it doesn't get better it
no there's only a certain limitation as
to what an actual the actual body can
hear right
um some people are really good at using
it those who are like born blind
are really good at using like the echo
location you've probably seen that where
people like
they click that's the like like orcas
and [ __ ]
yeah like for real yeah but you click
and that it's the same thing and it's
actually
the way you hear these little like
[ __ ] hairs in your ear canal right
the cilia yeah yeah i think it's
something like that
but it's like a feeling you sense it you
don't actually hear something it's like
i can tell
i click and there's a wall that there's
something in front of my face right now
yes i'm not good enough to tell how far
it is
sitting next to you the whole time
i can smell them yeah
see you got you lost sight i still don't
have my sense of smell we're both
sitting here handicapped oh you get the
covenant
i want to compare yeah it's been five
months now i still don't have
wow yeah my girl is still mixing away my
daughter's hair smells and things like
that so that's why i'm over here
thinking about
like man i miss the way her hair smells
and stuff and
yeah you know i wonder about touching
her face like that
yeah no yeah no face touching that's a
[ __ ]
yeah even with your son you don't do
that if you don't sit there and mold it
nope i mean let me ask you this and i'm
a bit different because i lost my sight
later in life
those who were born by like i said are
really good with using echolocation
they're sharp with that [ __ ]
i'm like i learned late in life you know
i use it a bit when i'm skating to guide
me like i'll have
like uh and we haven't talked about
skating yet that's what i want to get
i can i'll use like a little beeper box
that would be beep beep
beep beep beep off in the distance that
would kind of give me like an
orientation
that's coming up just where i where i
should head or where i shouldn't head
right
like maybe there's a pillar there or
something all right i just have a
million questions we're gonna get the
skating but
um all right let's do a positive here a
silver lining like
of all the things there are out there
for blind people
um services whatever what's the coolest
and then i want to know what's the
shittiest
thing that we as people do that is like
so
disruptive and you're like why the [ __ ]
do we
people do that it's uh
i mean technology just itself
has has made things so much easier like
my phone
being able to instantly send an email
understanding email
getting to read print like back in the
day do it before technology you had to
either read braille or you weren't
getting any information right
right um it's like being stuck [ __ ]
back before the printing press existed
like he's
literally like we're controlled by by
what we can read and
get access to so access to information
and knowledge has
improved greatly um
and then i mean for me the number one
greatest thing i did was get that cane
training
uh getting my some independence right
make that step to get independence back
and then you know now i [ __ ] travel
you know [ __ ] to japan and [ __ ] like
all kinds of stuff
so like those are the two big things
um what's the biggest pain in the ass
biggest pain in the ass is the way
people treat me
the uh um
it's it's the everyday stuff it's like i
felt bad because i was like hey we have
a flight of stairs and you're like ryan
i skate stairs it's not gonna be a
problem but then joey diaz gotta bum
these like at least
[Laughter]
it's a lot of i tried perspective yeah
it's all your perspective so
it's those little things man it's like
being at the airport and being with my
girl
and the [ __ ] tsa person being like
can i see his id
and like i'm saying instead of asking he
he is i i am he
like [ __ ] right here you say that
sometimes if i'm in a mood
like if i'm over it i'll [ __ ] do it
and like like
i get services to get me from like my
gate to to the
ride service area or something and like
the one time
i'm walking and i tell them right off
the bat i'm like hey like i can just
listen to your voice i'll
i'll follow you they're usually there
with the wheelchair to like try to keep
me in a wheelchair it's like no i'm good
i can walk
and uh do you think that most people do
come from the right place oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah just so
and that's why i hold my tongue nine
percent of the time because they you
just don't
know you know what i mean and i i'm
completely ignorant
to all this there's some times when i'll
bark back but that's
it's rare few and far between um
but like yeah i was getting the service
one time going from the airport and like
i i can hear the escalator and i told
her at the beginning like i don't need
an elevator like
stairs are fine right and she's like can
i hear the escalator we walk right past
it i know the airport like the back of
my hand by this point
and i'm like was that the escalator
right there did we just pass it like
yeah we're going the elevator i'm like
no no like
i'm good like i'll just use i'll use the
[ __ ] stairs then she's sitting there
right next to me like
oh my god be careful be careful be
careful i'm just like just walking onto
the [ __ ] escalator like
a normal person would do and it's [ __ ]
like that that [ __ ] drives me nuts
it's the little million little things
that add up
and like [ __ ]
you know not knowing where my shoes are
all those things
[ __ ] add up smashing my face on
[ __ ] something that's sticking out
like in my house
like these weird corners and getting
used to that and like
[ __ ] like that wears on me probably
don't move a lot huh
no i do like in my house i don't i don't
use my cane in my house
physically move around i mean move oh
move oh yeah homes
yeah i just bought a house like and this
ended last summer so like so what have
you installed in it to make your life
easier like because you now get to
produce this
instead of buying a house someone else
so what yeah
yeah i can read braille i'm [ __ ]
really bad at it are you because i
learned you know i learned
in [ __ ] yeah in grad school
for uh i ended up going to school for
vision rehabilitation therapy
so i finished like my bachelor's in
psychology and then got my master's
degree in
in vision rehab teaching so braille was
a class in there
i understood a little bit of braille in
the beginning but that like
made me go through the actual whole
[ __ ] contracted braille
grade tube rails when they caught but
that kind of [ __ ] throughout the house
um labels like that and then at small
things it's organization is the big
thing
like [ __ ] sugar goes here
it has to go heather sugar goes here
girl like that
where the [ __ ] is the sugar at the sugar
goes here i'm like a [ __ ] psychopath
now
it's [ __ ] sick why aren't why aren't
the towels folded right
yeah where the [ __ ] hands girl the
waffle
is supposed to be here dude that [ __ ]
drives me crazy you know that little
stuff is hard but
those are the main adaptions braille
dots braille
and uh there's other cool things like
there's a little thing that
you can put a label on then you can like
scan it and then it will read you what
it is as you whatever you want to save
it
so you can be like you know when you
have a thousand spices that have the
same container
you can actually label them all like
that yeah see i talk about
one of my coyotes she just hit me up
today um my cousin jennifer
same one that said that shirt uh-uh same
cousin
she uh she's almost completely deaf
and i remember going to her apartment
when i was home last time and she's like
come here let me show you something and
she's like lay on my bed and i lay on it
and it vibrates i'm like
you know showing me so i thought she
showed me some kinky [ __ ] i'm like oh my
god
i'll put a quarter exactly and she's
like no idiot that's my doorbell it's
your doorbell
yeah do you have that too no no yeah
that's her doorbell she can't hear her
yep and i was like ah vibration or
they'll have like a single mom
that'll flash like yeah that kind of
[ __ ] dude that's terrible there's people
blind deaf you know what i mean like
imagine that [ __ ]
i know that terrifies me because my
hearing is [ __ ] i'm like is my [ __ ]
hearing going dude
i don't know how people navigate like
that well speaking of navigating
let's talk about skating so you had
hated it for a while
got out of it gained a bunch of weight
depressed what got you back into it
especially because you you got sick of
it when you could still see
yep that's when i got into that
man cane training
helped excuse me cane training helps
more water
no i'm good i have another bite i'll
have to piss my pants in a second but
i'll go uh and navigate into the
bathroom's pain in the ass
but i [ __ ] so i yeah i do my cane
training
and this is a time when like i said i
started noticing the difference in the
way people treated me
and talked to me and these like
uh
actually here let me fill this water go
ahead
like edit this um
they don't have to pause this i'm gonna
watch you do this again because last
time last time you poured that
[ __ ] all the way to the top and
i
thought it was in the full box so i
watched what you did there you poured
against your finger first
i have my finger in here right now and i
can feel when my finger hits my finger
with my nasty with my nasty eyeball face
listen that is your cup to go anyway
even if it won that motherfucker's going
with you
uh um okay
skating when you're ready yeah so we
don't cut that out this is the same time
uh
there's actually a thing they make it
has two prongs called a liquid level
indicator
that will beep or buzz or it will
vibrate for those who can't hear for the
people who don't have fingers
if you've done fingers and don't have
ears
um fingers we're also getting to that
thumb over there
that's where we should have started the
story that was when i was seven
you can end on your thumb all right um
yeah i'm getting pissed off at the way
people are like treating me differently
it's like driving me nuts
so i started i made this i had the
instagram where i started doing [ __ ]
that you wouldn't expect
a blind person to do so it would be like
throwing a bullseye for darts
uh beer pong like i bounced one in and
then sunk one right back to back
like all these like little fun things
right
gain some traction it was cool and then
i filmed
uh i mean i hadn't thought about
skateboarding for a while like
i built a little bench that you would
like grind right
and i built a little batch and i was
like maybe i can [ __ ] do a trick on
this so i do like a front board slide on
it
and then got reposted well hold on
you're jumping all the way to front
board slides what was it like
getting on a board for the first time
without sight i mean that was that was
the day that was the day that was the
[ __ ] day you went and did it that day
that's the day i actually skated again
yeah no [ __ ] and you were doing tricks
already by
like muscle memory and females yeah i
just must i mean
yeah but that's what it is i was like
repeat something a million
[ __ ] times you can do it with your
eyes closed yeah not
stairs 11 available like the biggest set
i jumped down
um so like i was decent
at that level so like doing this basic
front board side isn't really like that
big of a deal
and i took it to uh a tennis court
and this one i had that little bit of
vision right so i would put the box
on like the white lines of the tennis
court which had really good contrast
from like it was like a red court and
then the white would like pop
so i could look off to like the left and
i could see that line
and use that as a guide and then use my
cane
to find the box i love i watch you skate
with a cane dude
yeah and at this time i was still using
that little bit of vision right
and like be able to find it could get me
to an obstacle
um and that gained like a little bit of
traction like people were stoked i got
shared like
through my buddy took the tony hawk
foundation um
and like i was like oh that's cool like
maybe i should let's see like what else
i could do like i didn't think
i would ever get the satisfaction out of
it that i did
as a kid right i'm like there's no way
i'm gonna be able to like progress
and like actually enjoy it and have a
good time
but i kind of just slowly started
skating more just to make these little
videos
and then i'm like damn i kind of want to
film like
another full-length skate part
and that became like my new goal uh
because it was i mean it's so weird
it would be like stopping comedy for you
right like
it's [ __ ] every as a kid it's ev
everything i thought about and ever did
um and like i always thought that no
matter what if i go blind i'm still
gonna skate
and then just [ __ ] life [ __ ] hit
me the blindness hit me and i was like
[ __ ] skateboarding's done like i
remember
physically i remember mentally making
the change in my brain of like
yep skateboarding's done like i had like
an old photo of me skating i got me look
at that frame that's kind of cool like
put it completely behind me
and then [ __ ] somehow fast forward to
now it's like
i found a way i actually i guess what
changed was i was actually able to like
progress
and like actually learn new tricks and
then it became fun to me and then it
became like oh this is a challenge of
damn how far can i take this and then it
was [ __ ]
getting hooked up with uh
real the board company i ride for uh
meeting jim
who's one of the owners of real uh and
then meeting
paul paul shire who's uh the main
the main tm for adidas damn
and then like having these opportunities
right
where i'm like oh damn like all right
i'm enjoying this
i'm progressing i know for a fact that i
haven't even [ __ ] hit the tip of the
[ __ ] iceberg yet as far as how far i
can push it
um i'm gonna [ __ ] go for this
and that was kind of a scary time
because i was going to grad school for
vrt and i had to make the decision of
uh skateboarding was really picking up
um i started getting some sponsors i
started getting some
actual money right and i'm like i don't
mean to interrupt but again you said
in order to technically be professional
your name has to be on a board that's
what pro
is in skating it it has to be on a board
from a legitimate
skateboard company i didn't know i
didn't know that's what i just thought
pro was if you got paid you were pro or
any
sponsor back in the 80s it was like if
you entered a contest as pro and you're
getting paid you were pro
right but it's become this weird like
stigma or like
um it's just badge of honor
that's become really important within
the skateboard culture of like
damn he made it like they you know now
it's like they do this huge like party
they'll throw like a huge party they'll
surprise
you with your [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are
they waiting on to put your name on the
board
what do you got i'm in this weird dude
it's i [ __ ] am somehow
listen when your name gets on a board
can i please get a board
of course yeah i can send you one we i'm
in this really weird gray area
i don't [ __ ] belong somehow i snuck
my way back in the skate industry you're
a honeydew bro
and i [ __ ] honey dude my way in yeah
i don't even i it blows my mind that
that i am where i am and then i've had
these opportunities
uh because that's how i feel every
[ __ ] it's insane like
as a kid like this i'm living literally
my childhood i try to check myself on
that too and say
look man if you'd have told 16 year old
you
that this [ __ ] was gonna go but it's
gonna be 30 years
it's gonna be 30 years yeah and you're
gonna have to go through some [ __ ]
and then if you make it through three
decades from now
right yeah and my buddy said that the
other day he's like well dude you
[ __ ]
you know you you handled like you made
it through your blindness and you
figured it out and that and that's why
you're at where you're at you know what
i mean like
i was like yeah i guess i deserve it
somewhat but i still you know you don't
feel like you ever deserve no i never
feel like i deserve anything
i know i need to feel more of that and
accepting too
yeah it's weird but um [ __ ] where was i
so like
yeah getting getting aligned with these
companies and then like
realizing like i said like all right i
got a long way to go like i know i can
progress
oh i'm in this weird gray area of uh
the the board company reel that i ride
for they did a braille board like a
raised braille graphic
and that was to raise money for this
foundation i started called keep pushing
um and i'm raising money to build like a
fully
adaptive skate park that's like has
everything you need
to use all of your other senses other
than promote the
chair whatever the links right now do
all that [ __ ]
dm me um at my dan the man cena
um i'm just setting up all the [ __ ] to
take in like all the funds
um you can use venmo you can [ __ ]
go through paypal right now um you send
me a link i'd like to contribute to that
yeah it'd be sick hell yeah thank you
um yeah and then i'm gonna build this
park and then it's gonna [ __ ] i'm
gonna fly in
kids and like families with kids with
visual impairments it's gonna be on my
flag
i bought this piece of chunk of land
right next to my home and they're going
to be able to come stay with me and then
i can teach them everything
hell yeah yeah i'm going to teach
everything from everything i learned
from as a vr team
all kids are blind kids uh i think i'm
going to start with blankets and then
it's [ __ ]
who you know wheelchairs whatever it's
going to be like this football
wheelchair this is what i'm saying like
i have these moments of feeling like
you know about my own [ __ ] but
yesterday or two days ago i watched
two guys in [ __ ] wheelchairs go down
the x games ramp one guy flipped
forward and landed it that's my man
aaron is it
wheels yeah he flipped forward and
landed the [ __ ] i'm like in the rest of
your upper body
can you paralyze that like no i it hurts
him to do that i guarantee that hurts
i know it's just because you can't you
use your legs don't mean you don't feel
that impact
i watched the way oh yeah and everything
and i was like [ __ ] he's gonna paralyze
his whole body
i know and is it the same guy that i saw
then do the back backflip or is that or
there's a couple guys
i can't be many dudes out there doing
that he's he's the only one
there's a girl who's actually done a
backflip on a wheelchair but he's the
[ __ ] dude he's the one
when i go to these adaptive contests i
can't [ __ ] beat him he's [ __ ] at
he just backflips on the [ __ ]
wheelchair like i can't compete with
that [ __ ]
i tell him every time i'm gonna learn
how to backflip [ __ ] and i'm
taking your ass off
he wears a helmet and all this um are
there any other blind skaters out there
yeah dude there's [ __ ]
uh there's one grew up like 20 minutes
from me
no who lost his sight he got he got an
infection
i think it's a [ __ ] mrsa or some [ __ ]
a staph infection
ended up going into septic shock and
like [ __ ] lost his sight and woke up
[ __ ] blind and like 90 pounds made
his way back to the board and [ __ ]
nick mullens you can check him out on he
[ __ ] kills it he's so good at skating
um and then justin bishop he just came
out with this another skate park
um he's actually killing it
they [ __ ] kill it and like that's my
goal is to help like our push is to get
in paralympics 2028
i'll be eight
we're trying to get it in the
paralympics all right so that i can't
get i'll be [ __ ] 41.
but i'm gonna [ __ ] try to compete why
should there be anything for skating
that's a young man's game everything's
so is comedy yeah
young man everything's a young yeah i
mean i [ __ ] believe me i know hey
there's a chance i'm i'm gonna go for it
for sure yeah
but right now where it's all in the
process right i'm on like the i'm on
like a committee for like the usa
skateboarding and death the sports
committee and we're pushing to do that
we're having the first uh do tour is
like you ever heard of do tour
big [ __ ] skate contest they're having
their first adaptive street
street contest so you can watch me i
think i don't know if they're going to
televise the adaptive where is it going
it's in des moines it's in uh i think we
skate the 24th
so i'll be there i'll be in [ __ ] was
it iowa right
yeah des moines iowa this is heaven no
it's iowa
that's right um yeah as you can [ __ ]
watch me skate there so that'll be
[ __ ] really dope but
shit's picking up like there's a bunch
of other blind skaters uh we don't have
our own division right i gotta compete
against [ __ ] backflip and aaron
but it's all good man nobody's going to
beat that guy no
one's going to beat aaron and he's been
i mean unless you do a goddamn mctwist
he's been doing it that [ __ ] was it's
it's insane dude that's that rock back
and then i was like
yeah and then he went
he's insane he did like a 360 backflip
on the mega ramp that's incredible he
tried to do the loop you know that loop
thing
yeah though his wheels thing
yeah he tried to do that all the way
around he couldn't get the speed the
ramp wasn't big enough
because he like lose he has like little
wheels in the front the [ __ ] wobbling
yeah
he can't maintain his speed he [ __ ]
fell and landed on his head and [ __ ]
he's like all right i got it either they
got to build a
bigger ramp or not does that have to be
bigger or smaller it's got to be bigger
or bigger
um maybe you could do it i feel like a
smaller circle he could probably get
more
yeah you might be able to get around
around that [ __ ] yeah that's true what
do i know
but he's yeah he's [ __ ] i can't say
enough good things about that dude dan i
can't say enough good things about you
dude this has been
a [ __ ] amazing this is one of my
favorite episodes
i have to say man you're incredible um
thank you for coming on something i ask
all guests who come home for the first
time is advice they give to their 16
year old self so i'm curious to hear
what you would say because at that point
you've already been told you're going to
lose sight
16 man i would uh i'd say don't change a
thing because at that time i was like
the freest you know i worry about so
much [ __ ] you know like
just life and like at that age dude
i was the most free spirited
carefree person in the world so just
[ __ ] just keep pushing keep doing you
honestly um try to hold on to that hold
on to 16 for as long as you can
a little ditty yeah
um please again promote your social
media everything you want
yep yep just dan the man cena across the
board all platforms uh
instagram's the biggest one youtube
trying to grow that
[ __ ] and then yeah if you want to
donate would be huge for the keep
pushing stuff get this park built
get some kids flying out and uh just
direct message me is the best way on
instagram or you can always email me
um on my [ __ ] podcast incited with
dan mancina
email me inside it at uh insighted
podcast
gmail.com so dude thank you so much this
is a great episode
great episode thank you i appreciate you
hell yeah uh as always ryan sickler on
all social media ryansickler.com
subscribe to the youtube channel
talk to you all next week
[Music]
you